[Music]
hey this is an amazing moment on so many
levels look at that huge smile on Queen
Elizabeth's face I mean here's my
question how often do you see the Queen
smiling like that hardly ever right and
imagine the pressure on naked Marco
she's traveling side by side for the
Queen and she has already something want
to awkward moment we have all the
details inside their Oriole girls trip
this was Megan's first appearance with
the Queen without Harry arriving in
Cheshire England via the Royal train the
occasion signaled that the queen is all
aboard team naked this is the Queen
extending an arm of friendship but not
just that she's tutoring Megan she is
making the time in her very busy
schedule to say to Megan okay I'm going
to show you personally the Royal ropes
big uns one-of-a-kind belted cape dress
was created by Claire wait Keller for Ag
paunchy that's the same designer off her
wedding gown
the 92 year old monarch and her
granddaughter in-law seemed a very
chummy together while seated on the
stage Megan whispered into the Queen's
air and have the Queen in stitches of
laughter and it was a very rare moment a
very unguarded moment you don't often
see the Queen in giggles
they were entertained by local
schoolchildren the Duchess was wearing
brand-new pearl and diamond earrings a
gift from the Queen we don't know
whether they were bought new or whether
they were from the Queen's personal
collection at a wild greeting the crowd
the royal newly weds called Harry the
best husband and gushed about married
life
but there was one minor situation the
Queen always walks ahead of all other
members of the royal family she started
to enter her car first but after a word
with Meghan the Duchess enter anniver
she had she turned to the Queen and
asked the Queen what her preference was
and the Queen actually said you go first
and Megan did so she abided by protocol
their joint appearance have been less
than one month after the Royal Wedding
by contrast Duchess Kate didn't make a
trip with the Queen until nearly a year
into her marriage in a rare interview
Kate said she was quite nervous I went
without William so as well the prints of
about that everyone teases me in the
family that I spent far too long
tattooing I think I've still got to
learn a little bit more and to pick up a
few more tips
[Music]